have you ever tried to recreate
something you found on Pinterest and it
ended up turning into a complete
disaster if so don't worry you're not
alone Texas is the home of so many
creative ideas from baby pictures to
delicious recipes but when things take a
turn for the worst the results aren't
pretty if you're new to our channel
don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up because today we're sharing the 10
most hilarious Pinterest fails ever hair
flip this girl is really showing us her
stuff while doing an epic hair flip in
the middle of the ocean with droplets of
water creating a perfect semicircle and
the Sun gazing beautifully in the
background there's no wonder so many
people have tried and failed to recreate
this perfect scene this girl is looking
more frightened than anything she knows
halfway through her hair flip that this
picture is going to be a complete
disaster kid tower gone wrong it just
doesn't get any more adorable than this
these siblings were stacked on top of
each other to create a cute kid tower
don't they look so angelic and peaceful
seeing this photo really gave the
Pinterest users the inspiration to
recreate it using their own children but
when it comes to taking photos of kids
things don't always go as planned these
kids look bored out of their minds and
we wouldn't be surprised if they told
their parents hurry up and take the
picture already
and look at the poor newborn baby
hanging on for dear life the expression
on his face says it all this Pinterest
recreation is a definite fail fake
candid moment candid moments with the
ones you love are some of the best
photos that we cherish for a lifetime
these besties locked hands giggled and
smile together to create the ultimate
picture that definitely deserves the
hashtag BFF goals so when three guys
tried to emulate this photo it didn't
necessarily give us the warm and fuzzy
feelings we were expecting but we have
to give them an A for effort for making
us completely bust up laughing just by
looking at the hilarious expressions on
their faces glitter shoes if you ever
wanted to design your own
use and clothing Pinterest is loaded
with ideas for you to unleash your inner
Coco Chanel this DIY glitter shoot
tutorial looks easy enough right all it
takes is a pair of shoes some glue and a
bunch of glitters to turn your shoes
from bland into glam but this Pinterest
user obviously underestimated her
abilities instead of turning her shoes
into shiny and sparkling Footwear they
ended up looking more like a drippy
gooey mess
pumpkin disaster here's another
Pinterest photo that incorporates an
adorable baby haha look how cute he is
with his tiny little hat and his teeny
tiny feet sticking out of the pumpkin we
can't blame other parents for wanting to
recreate this scene with their own
children but maybe they should have
loved this one to the pros this baby is
totally not having it and the look of
terror on his face makes us feel so bad
for him
but we still can't stop ourselves from
laughing we just hope his parents didn't
leave him sitting in the pumpkin for too
long
flexibility failed these friends headed
out to the beach to show off their
flexibility in front of the crashing
waves to pull off this move you have to
have a lot of balance and you definitely
can't be a total [ __ ] these friends
decided to give the same move a shot and
as you can see things didn't go as
planned they can barely lift your legs
into the air nice try you guys ice cream
cone cupcakes YUM don't these ice cream
cone cupcakes look delicious we're
thinking about making some of our own
how hard can it be all you need are some
ice cream cones
cake batter frosting and sprinkles right
easy peasy wait not so fast if your cone
tip over into the baking pan you'll be
left with a complete disaster and that's
something this Pinterest user found out
the hard way
happy holidays the holidays are the
perfect time to get your baby all
dressed up to take holiday photos these
parents decided to ditch the miniature
Santa costume and check their baby out
in glowing lights instead the baby seems
to be having a good time and that was
more than enough motivation this
Pinterest user needed to recreate this
photo on their own but sadly their baby
wasn't a happy camper and instead of
looking innocently into the camera this
kid is screaming their head off crayon
art the melted wax in this crayon art
creates the perfect drippy and colorful
effect that would look great hanging on
any wall we're not the only ones who are
intrigued by this DIY art project and
many Pinterest users have desperately
tried to recreate this artwork on their
own instead of gluing the crayons at the
top this DIY are used a bunch of duct
tape and as for the melted wax that's
supposed to cascade beautifully down the
paper it looks like this person started
the process of melting the wax and then
completely gave up and threw in the
towel better luck next time in short who
wears short shorts everyone on Pinterest
apparently this DIY frayed short
tutorial fixed interest users into a
frenzy these shorts look pretty simple
to recreate but someone's high hopes
came to a screeching halt when they
debuted their DIY creation they aimed
for cute high-waisted shorts with just
the right amount of frayed edges but
they were left with an odd combination
that looks like a mixture between shorts
and bikini bottoms you should probably
leave the viy fashion designs to the
pros and just run out and buy a pair of
shorts instead which of these Pinterest
sales is the most hilarious to you react
in the comments section below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
[Music]